atomicar is a first person action RPG
set in a world of Killer Robots the game
isn't the best at explaining some of its
mechanics so I've put together a list of
tips that I would have loved to have
early on here are 9 things I wish I knew
when I started playing atomic heart
the early hours of atomic heart the game
walks you through the purchase of shock
an elemental upgrade for your sentient
polymer glove Charles this tutorial as
well as my experience with similar games
led me to believe that this was the only
Elemental upgrade available to me that
early on in fact Charles even says more
skills will become available to you soon
but this is not 100 the truth as all of
the glove upgrades are available right
away you just need enough materials for
them atomic heart does not tell you this
but if you head back into the Nora
machine following the free tutorial
upgrades you'll see that you have around
30 neuropolymer that can be used this is
just enough to afford the polymetric
shield by itself or frostbite in the
polymetric jet together the latter will
set you up with three elemental powers
right out the gate giving you an early
advantage against your foes the best
part is that you're not locked into your
decision here you can turn abilities at
any point in the game at Anora for 100
refund of resources so if you'd rather
try out the shield ability first you can
do so and still try out the other two
abilities later and vice versa the game
eventually gives you this information
but it's great to know sooner so you can
start tinkering with your playstyle in
the opening hours this awesome refund
feature also works when dismantling
weapons and consumables but you won't
need to worry about the weapons part
just yet this is because unlike the
glove upgrades all the weapons are not
available from the start and need to be
unlocked using found blueprints we'll
talk a little more about weapons later
in the video but for now let's keep
discussing neuropolymer and glove
upgrades a great way to get those
upgrades as soon as possible is to make
sure you scan the environment after a
fight so that you don't miss out on any
loot from Fallen enemies throughout the
game's different combat encounters
you'll be forced to move around a lot in
order to avoid getting hit sometimes it
can be easy to forget about the bot you
defeated towards the beginning of an
enemy wave across the room or down the
long hallway from where you're currently
standing scanning helps you find the
parts you couldn't loot In the Heat of
battle so that you're always getting the
most out of each fight anything
highlighted in blue has resources left
to scavenge if nothing in the vicinity
is highlighted you've successfully
looted everything you can but scanning
isn't just useful for dead enemies or
cabinet-filled rooms you can also make
use of this feature during combat I
didn't use this a whole lot during my
playthrough as enemies are fast and have
a tendency to get up close and personal
but keep in mind you can scan enemies to
reveal what they are weak and resistant
to I found this to be most helpful in
situations in which I was facing a
tougher enemy all you have to do is wait
for the right opening otherwise you'll
be dodging out of the way before the
scan is even complete luckily the Dodge
can still be triggered during a scan in
fact dodging is still available during a
few other actions and character
animations as well my favorites are
dodging while healing and while charging
a heavy attack as you progress in atomic
heart you will have the option to
upgrading to one-handed healing but
until you have that you'll be stuck with
no way to attack as you use both hands
to recover your health dodging away from
lasers punches blades and more without
canceling the heel animation is a major
Plus for the game and can make a huge
difference when you only have a sliver
of Health left a similar thing can be
said for charging heavy attacks further
into the game you can decrease the time
needed to charge an attack but until
then you can take comfort in knowing
that your charge won't go away if you
keep holding the button while dodging to
safety depending on your difficulty and
if you're following the tips I've listed
so far in this video Atomic Hearts
combat encounters can be a little
overwhelming aside from the telekinesis
upgrade I felt like I didn't have many
way ways to effectively control a crowd
that is until I unlocked and installed
the EMP generator for the electro this
attachment is most effective against
mechanical enemies but can still have an
effect on biological ones as well the
EMP generator is located in a break room
close to the algae Workshop there is a
chest on the right side of the room
across from the Nora machine so you
won't have to do any major hunting for
it if you're constantly dipping into
these rooms in order to manually save or
upgrade your gear and there's a very
small chance that you'll miss out on
this attachment you may already have it
unlocked and didn't even notice once you
have the EMP generator or any other of
the blueprints you want you'll probably
be starving for certain resources in
order to make that weapon a reality
however finding those resources can be a
little easier if you know where to look
luckily Atomic Arc gives you that
information right on the crafting screen
all you have to do is hover over the
required resource and select it you will
then be taken to a new screen that shows
you which enemies drop a certain
material and how frequently they do so
similar to my tip from earlier in the
video you can also take advantage of the
dismantle feature in order to get
materials that you need for crafting
what you want this is just one of the
reasons you're going to want to pay
attention to your Nora Storage and check
it often there are plenty of times
throughout my playthrough in which I
didn't realize I had tons of Health
capsules ammo and more in the Nora
storage that could have been being used
to prevent me from getting my teeth
kicked in because of this area's
tendency to get overstocked it can be a
great place to comb through when you
need materials I did this a lot early on
with Fatboy ammo I knew I didn't have
the blueprint for this weapon and wasn't
planning on Crafting it anytime soon so
I always dismantle the rockets in order
to get what I needed at that moment this
final tip may seem very obvious but it
took me longer than I'd like to admit to
figure it out you can switch weapons
using the left and right buttons on the
d-pad of your controller I've been so
accustomed to you using the triangle
button on PlayStation controllers to
switch my gun in FPS games that I
frustratingly fired off my shock ability
tons of times by accident sick of always
using the radio menu to change my
weapons I finally pressed enough buttons
to randomly figure out that the swap is
mapped to the d-pad it doesn't feel
great to use and I still wish there was
Button remapping built into the console
version but it's better than nothing I
guess those are all nine of the things I
wish I knew when I started my
playthrough of atomic heart hit the
comment section and let me know some of
the things you wish you knew that I may
not have covered in this video so that
we can continue to help each other out
if you haven't already make sure you
watch our review of atomic heart like
this video if you found it helpful and
subscribe to Gamespot for more
foreign